how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel
and of course spider-man no way home and
today we have an
insane plot leak one that actually
sounds pretty legitimate but one that
also makes me pretty mad and i think
will make a lot of fans mad as well
if this actually happens in the movie
and if you stick around till the end
you'll see why
and i do have an update on that
spider-man no way home trailer but first
big congrats to gabe vlogs for winning
the stormbreaker giveaway he's been
contacted and it's on his way to him but
i have
a new giveaway starting very soon that
i'll announce hopefully this week it's
one that i think you guys
will really really like so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so let's first talk real quick about the
spider-man no way home trailer and when
to expect it because i got a little bit
more information
over the past couple of days for
starters i actually talked to a local
manager
at my local theater and he confirmed
that they do
have it i also talked to some other
people that i won't mention by name but
they have some pretty big contacts and
they have confirmed
with these contacts yes the first teaser
trailer is indeed finished and has been
distributed to
theaters now as far as when it's going
to drop i couldn't get an
actual release date but it sounds like
it could happen any day within the next
two weeks from what i understand
they really only send the trailers out
when they're good to go and about to
release to the public
so we are very very close and as always
if i hear anything else i'll be sure to
update everybody
and now we'll start with this plot leak
which again sounds really really good
but i don't know if i want it and after
you hear the plot lake you'll all have
to let me know what you think about it
in the comments down below so i can kind
of feel the vibe for it but it sounds
very legitimate and of course as the
teaser comes out and some people have
actually seen it we get more and more
leaks so
it could be very legitimate so let's
dive right in it says
peter is on the run after the identity
reveal in spider-man far from home
ned and mj are with him since their
accomplices to his
crimes and accomplices and crimes are
both in quotes
it then says that doctor strange at
happy's request
finds them in a homeless shelter
undercover where he brings them back to
the sanctum
and tells them to lay low while he
figures out a way to fix everything
there's actually a story in the comic
line where doctor strange mr fantastic
and iron man actually help erase the
memory of spider-man
peter parker from everybody in the world
so doctor strange could definitely
figure out a way to fix this whole
identity crisis but then it goes on to
say
in the sanctum peter comes across a sort
of
bigger on the inside prison where green
goblin doc ock and sandman
from the raimi universe and the lizard
and electro from the amazing spider-man
universe are being held
willem dafoe's green goblin manages to
trick peter into thinking that their
universe's spider-man
were corrupt and killed them it tells
them that peter needs to release them so
they can save their own universes
so peter ends up freeing them and they
escape into the city it then says that
doctor strange then shows up and
tears peter a new one he explains that
he had been holding them in this prison
due to the instability in the multiverse
connected to each dimension's
oscorp experimenting with
interdimensional travel
and he says that peter has a
responsibility now to stop them
willem dafoe's green goblin leads the
villains to the mcu oscorp building to
try and steal prototype interdimensional
technology
peter tries to stop them but he gets his
butt kicked and thrown aside
strange ends up rescuing him and says
that they're going to need more help
and strange and peter travel into the
raimiverse and into the amazing
spider-man universe and we see how the
peters are living after the conclusion
of their series toby maguire spider-man
is married to mj and they have a
daughter
andrew garfield spider-man is now a
college professor
and i would personally really really
love to see this i would really love to
see
toby mcguire's spider-man with mj having
a kid living a somewhat normal life
and andrew garfield spider-man as a
professor i would love to see both of
these and i really hope this happens
especially since we were going to get a
fourth toby maguire sam raimi spider-man
and never did
the plot leak goes on to say through
their connection to their home universes
the villains sense that their spider-men
are likely on their way
they used the oscorp device to open a
one-way portal into the amazing
spider-man universe
with the amazing spider-man rhino
barging through the sinister six
are goblin och sandman the lizard
electro and the rhino willem dafoe's
osborne realizes the way to open two-way
portals and thus get back to their own
universes
is to power the osborne device with a
stark power core
the green goblin ends up getting this
device while the other sinister six
distract the spider-man allowing him
time to get it from stark industries
the sinister six go to battle with all
three spider-men at the statue of
liberty the green goblin plans on using
the statue of liberty to open portals
back to their own worlds and
to trap the spider-man here so they can
no longer interfere with their plans
in their own respective universes toby
maguire's spider-man is beaten
way harder than the other younger
spider-man and
ends up dying after the battle and this
is where i start to get kind of really
mad and upset because i definitely don't
want this to happen but i'll talk about
it more at the end
norman osborne's green goblin finally
shows up at the end with the device
and ned norman osborne activates the
device
but they managed to stop him and protect
ned in a 2v1 fight with him
but the green goblin manages to miss the
two spider-man with a pumpkin bomb
and ends up killing ned another part
that i get really mad about
tom holland's spider-man nearly kills
the green goblin but
andrew garfield spider-man stops him
from becoming a villain
like them the sinister six get locked
back up in strange's prison
and tom holland spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man attend toby maguire
spider-man's funeral in the raimi
universe
and then seemingly part ways tom holland
spider-man in the mcu ends up turning
himself
in but he ends up being successfully
defended from
murder charges by his lawyer matt
murdock
aka daredevil however his secret
identity issue is not resolved as
everybody still knows that peter parker
is spider-man one of the final scenes is
of tom holland spider-man going up to
ned's grave and talks about how he feels
responsible for his death it's at this
point that andrew garfield's spider-man
shows back up in his universe and he
gives the responsibility talk to tom
holland spider-man
tom holland spidey realizes that ned
like uncle ben
tony stark and toby maguire's peter
parker would want him to still be a hero
it then says that the final swing is of
both tom
and andrew spider-man in the streets of
the mcu
new york now this plot leak overall
sounds pretty cool
i like how everything is incorporated
with the other two universes i like the
fact that the multiverse is already kind
of falling apart and strange has already
been doing his job
kind of protecting the entire multiverse
by locking up some of the villains now
norman osborne is a genius
and if anybody as far as villains are
concerned are going to know how to open
up these portals it's going to be him
at least anybody that the mcu is
prepared to introduce
this also follows other leaks that we've
heard before that primarily involve
around the green goblin
being the main villain which at this
point in time many different reliable
insiders have reported to be true
in fact last week daniel rpk backed up
the fact again that the green goblin is
the main villain and if you consider the
fact that multiverse of
madness is coming right after this it
would make sense that the madness would
begin
in spider-man no way home now i actually
really like this plot leak but the only
part i hate about it is the fact that
toby maguire's spider-man would die
this is something that i just don't want
to happen he's my personal favorite
spider-man and i would hate to see him
die on screen
especially if you just showed him being
married to mj and having a daughter
now it does make sense that he would be
a little bit out of shape
compared to the other two younger
spider-man but i would really hate for
him to die and i think it would be a
shame
the same thing goes for ned i don't hate
ned dying as much as i hate toby dying
because it wouldn't be the first time
that spider-man in a movie
lost a true best friend toby lost harry
andrew garfield spider-man lost gwen
it would make sense that there is a loss
for tom holland's peter parker in the
film
however is it necessary that's kind of
my only real question about this
i think it could add to the future
movies but i think we'll have to see how
it's executed but overall this plot leak
actually sounds pretty good now of
course take it with a grain of salt as
always but if the whole thing isn't true
i definitely think that there are parts
of this that are for sure true
but let me know what you think about
this and specifically let me know how
you would feel
if toby maguire spider-man died in
spider-man no way home
and ned and of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof